- So wait while I have you here,
I should know how to throw football.
Now, I feel like I
learned when I was a kid,
but I don't know if I'm doing it right.
So since you're here and so
I will have bragging rights
to all of my friends and family.
- Absolutely.
- Will you teach me?
- 100%.
- Okay, okay.
(audience clapping)
Let's do it.
I'm so excited.
I think I know how, but I don't know.
My first question, these are gigantic.
- They are?
- I don't remember them
being (laughs) this big.
This is huge.
Okay, wait.
So I feel like don't you have a?
See you don't hold yours.
- [Troy] I hold it a little differently.
I hold it differently.
- You hold yours differently.
Wait, why?
- It's just the way it's
always worked for me.
- [Kelly] You like the
texture on your hand?
- So you can't hold it the way I hold it.
- [Kelly] I heard you're
supposed to have your finger,
is that not right?
- [Troy] Yeah, normally most quarterbacks
would hold it more like
this, where you have.
- [Kelly] I can't, my hand is so small.
- [Troy] Where you have three fingers on--
- [Both] The lace laces.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I barely have one, I
hold it way back here,
on the back of the ball.
- Yeah, but you,
look at your hand and mine.
- I got big hands.
- [Kelly] Yeah. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
Yeah, 'cause like that's gigantic.
So I can do that, I can't
hold it in any other way,
but how do you?
Aren't you supposed to let it spin?
- [Troy] I bet you're an athlete.
- I'm totally an athlete.
- You know, throw it, spin it.
- Spin it off the tips, right?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Now what's gonna be embarrassing
is if I miss and you hit.
(everyone laughing)
- Not for me. (laughs)
- I literally have not throw
a ball in quite a while.
- (laughs) I am looking
so forward to this.
Oh gosh!
There's no way I'm gonna hit that.
Are you good at carnival games?
I'm not.
- [Troy] Not bad.
- Okay, oh, go ahead.
- Want me to go?
- Yeah, go, show me how.
(audience cheering)
- [Troy] All right. (laughs)
- Oh my God.
I feel like I should
be able to get closer,
I'm gonna try from here.
Here I go.
- Okay.
- Okay, okay, okay.
(audience encouraging)
Oh, no.
Wait, wait.
No, wait.
- You did it! (laughs)
(audience cheering)
- Troy Aikman, everybody.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you.